so unfortunately uh we are going very
much the wrong direction in a lot of
ways in this country when it comes to
just common decency and quite frankly
law and order now i know that law and
order is typically a phrase weaponized
by the right against the left but
we now have
even fox news host tucker carlson
talking about fake vaccination cards a
card
that looks like a real cdc card saying
you've been vaccinated against covid but
it's fake tucker carlson referring to
these cards as and those who get them as
desperate acts
by good law abiding people now it's
against the law so how do you call
something that's against the law
law abiding it's weird we're going to
look at the clip in a moment daily beast
writing about it
tucker carlson advocates for the
unvaccinated to get fake vaccine cards
quote act of desperation
taking his criticism of vaccine mandates
to a whole new level
tucker seemingly advocated for
unvaccinated people to obtain fake
vaccination cards claiming it's not a
serious crime
but instead an act of desperation for
law-abiding americans who have been
forced into a corner
earlier this week manhattan d.a cyrus
vance jr announced 15 people are now
facing charges over a conspiracy to
forge
covet 19 vaccine cards and fraudulently
enter
people into new york's vaccination
database 13 of the people charged for
buying the bogus cards are quote
believed to work in front line in
essential employee settings including
hospitals and nursing homes
the scheme involved a forger who
allegedly advertised the sale of fake
cards on her instagram account for 200
bucks apiece
for another 250 a long island nurse
would then allegedly enter the buyer's
name into the new york state
immunization information system
according to vance's office roughly 250
of these cards were sold
in an effort to avoid vaccination
mandates
the article explains that carlson has
been a loud vaccine skeptic has railed
against mandates
said all sorts of stuff so let's go to
the video
here is tucker carlson take a listen
so in good conscience
they've risked their careers to preserve
their right to bodily autonomy and now
they're in jail for that so understand
that
when you
um offer a fake vaccine card to someone
or
you falsely enter someone into a state's
vaccination database tucker is saying
these are almost heroic people
taking a risk to preserve bodily
autonomy
these are crimes this is fraud that's
what it is and they claim to be about
law and order about listen this is the
law
now these arrests will be used to
justify digital health passports for the
entire american population that is true
save this tape
in fact cyrus vance has already enlisted
big tech to help root out the
disobedient in new york quote we need
companies like facebook to take action
to prevent the fraud happening on their
platform now even the use of the term
disobedient is just a loaded term
because what we're talking about when
people lie about vaccination status is
number one it's a crime if it's a fake
cdc card you're using a federal agent
you're fraudulently using a federal
agency sealed as a crime
um but the use of the term disobedient
is obviously cynical and tongue-in-cheek
and it's meant to say these are people
who won't be bullied by the man it said
making selling and purchasing forged
vaccination cards are serious crimes
with serious public safety there's
certainly crimes there's no doubt about
that sequences
end quote except that's a lie
buying a fake vaccination card is not a
quote serious crime it's not even close
to a serious crime
buying a fake vaccination card is an act
of desperation
by decent law abiding americans who have
been forced into a corner by tyrants now
quite literally
when you commit a crime you're not law
abiding these are the people who say
they hold the principle of law and order
above everything and he's essentially
saying these are decent law-abiding
law breakers
they are desperate and good people
you know it's a serious crime
forcing americans to take drugs they
don't need or want that's a very serious
crime now of course that is a complete
mix-up here that uh and and that is not
actually what is taking place
employers can say
if you want to work here
then you must be vaccinated if you want
to shop here the government can say our
employees can do the same there is even
the legal argument based on the 90 1905
case jacobson v massachusetts that the
government could mandate vaccinations
more generally but that's not actually
what has taken place and let's hope in
the end someone is punished for it
severely
yeah so tucker's saying that it's the
people
uh
requiring vaccines that are the people
that should be punishing punished so
buying fake vaccine cards violates the
law that by definition means you are not
law abiding making and selling fake
vaccine cards violates the law that by
definition means you are not law abiding
now tucker has talked about this before
about people who get fake papers to go
someplace that they wouldn't otherwise
be allowed
but he wasn't calling them law abiding
then
he was sort of using more muted language
now he's just going and saying it it's
it's the trump thing of what you're
seeing with your own eyes you can't or
shouldn't believe
these are law abiding but they're
committing a crime they're breaking a
law here's the law that they are
breaking but these are decent
law-abiding people this is really scary
stuff and of course it's only going to
encourage more of it now with joe
biden's federal employee vaccine
requirement i can only imagine that
these people are going to go absolutely
crazy
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
just for documentaries my girlfriend and
i have been using the curiosity stream
platform at home non-stop i can tell you
from personal experience much better
documentary selection than netflix hulu
or amazon on
stream i'm always finding documentaries
by the world's best filmmakers stuff you
can't find on other streaming services
last month they added a ton of awesome
new titles to the library i just
finished watching becoming martian
about the future of the human species
and its possible path through mars but
there's documentaries on every topic
imaginable science nature history
politics if you love documentaries the
way i do you are not going to find a
better source of brand new award-winning
docs anywhere else curiosity stream is
giving my audience 25 off that means you
can subscribe for just 15 bucks a year
very reasonable considering the endless
number of super quality documentary
content that you have access to
just go to curiositystream.compacman
the link is right underneath this video